let's move on to our top photos right
now all right as part of their obey your
verse lyrical collection sprite will be
releasing 16 limited edition cans each
will feature a different and
inspirational rap verse the rapper's
included in the campaign are Drake nas
the notorious b.i.g and rakim y these
rappers you ask well because they're all
celebrated for honest self-expression
and being true to themselves that's
according to the sprite press release is
it on a self-expression and being true
to yourself in the nature of rap I
suspect they're being celebrated because
they agreed to a contract right
lyrically I'm supposed to represent I
think that's very truthful say is that
yes that is there's nothing more it's
almost it's it almost deep circles back
in on itself doesn't it it's sort of it
anyway this next one is almost dominique
strauss-kahn of nature well yeah right
biochemist certain hans sexist comments
that female scientists should only work
in single-sex labs has sparked quite the
uproar on twitter hunt said quote
trouble with girls is they fall in love
with you you fall in love with them I'm
that when they're criticized they cried
so female scientists are tweeting photos
of themselves as it is hashtag I'm
looking down the hall I could dig myself
mrs. there it is as a whole this is
ain't nothing I sure hi I asked for
these photos to be included today
because my wife who's been spending a
lot of time in a lab recently thought
they were hilarious and they're like
that that's only we've not plumb the
depths of the photos that are available
on Twitter right now with women to
attempting to pipette in a distractingly
sexy way it's an amazing mean if you see
that you'll know where it comes from
he's Nobel Prize winner by the way
through las foto Laverne Cox made an
impromptu appearance at the orange is
the new black's Times Square takeover is
she found out from Twitter fans after
the huge display and headed down to see
for herself the season three of orange
is the new black was originally
scheduled to premiere on netflix friday
but was released early happy binge
watching this weekend we really believe
that was an accident the Laverne Cox
just kind of heard about it and the
Twitter told her she just showed up to
turn out by jill has a great story today
there's almost too much good quality
stuff on TV yeah I like your food people
that watch a lot I guess
what is your zone there's just under I'm
taking a breather after madman I tell
you what's good quality has been our top
photos for this last season so you want
to say a very special goodbye and good
luck and thank you so much to our top
photos editor in chief Eric orange is
gonna go I just gonna go run Twitter it
that's right he's been deaf no the
photos are amazing everything and we
really thank you for them particularly
all the space photos that made Tom happy
in the sailing photos that make me happy
thing yeah Eric get out of here Lexi's
better